off one to ten with what like a lot of
women when I go on the street I'm a time
and as soon as I say oh so you look the
same as Rihanna and their face goes
right and aren't they just freezing
they're like yeah remember one to ten I
get called Rihanna all the time
if I had her money maybe
so that means you're adjustable seven
then I said humble 8.5 that's humble 8.5
hmm it's hard to be humble over seven
baby I know I'm working with you just
own it the novel you know I just say it
I'm an 8.5 a humble 8.5
can I just ask are you when you say 8.5
do you say um just because of your look
so the whole pack the whole package
actually no no I say probably looks
whole package nine whole package nine
and and if you want to just say looks
815
okay at five I think you think you're in
the top 15 of beauty
why aren't you in Hollywood where are
your modeling contracts my modeling
contracts are not there because I'm not
trying to be a model they find you no
but I don't want to be they find people
look at what people are finding me for
that's good are you gonna post on the
spot now no she's a model well yeah like
I've literally
um like just going from posting on
Instagram and stuff
um I like have been offered to work for
Bottega and puma and like collaborations
with like Dua Lipa just from like
posting on Instagram like they do they
have just found me naturally but also
like when I've applied I always get like
replies I sound so [ __ ] big-headed
but yeah like I do I like I applied for
Willamina like yesterday and like this
is like one of the biggest modern like
things in the world I do feel big-headed
now like they replied but it's results
so basically you're prettier than me
because you're a model and I'm not wow
no I don't think that I think beauty is
very new I'm saying the business
I'm saying results mean something you
know but they don't I'm I'm saying I do
it is a subject
is very subjective I do agree with you
because beauty is so subjective like one
person might look at me and then be like
[ __ ] like you're sorry no one person
will be like no I think no matter what I
think there is certain things
um you can look at someone even if
they're different no matter what race
they are no matter what
um what texture their hair is no matter
um you know how they behave their
confidence you can look at a person even
like someone like you and I I mean we
differ so much and someone would say
okay she's better looking than this
person right because it suggests no I
think like yeah because you've got to
remember there's a general consensus for
beauty that's been going on for a
hundred years no no I think you can just
look at someone and say sure
like obese people for example they're
certain names
like being a model you have to have a
certain standard because they they're
going to put you as a face of their
brand yeah and being pretty is another
thing right yeah you need a symmetrical
fate like symmetry that's what I'm
saying like people that are model level
pretty get model level results yeah I've
never posted an Instagram photo and had
a modeling agency reach out to me but I
don't think it's crazy like top 15 of
beauty that's a lot that's really really
amazing Beauty on symmetry is very
dangerous because Beauty does not
actually no that's the standards based
on what people are trying to tell you
wait wait wait don't know it's not just
symmetry it's also your weight okay
with blue eyes
scientifically when you look at somebody
if somebody's face is symmetrical
automatically your brain is don't start
permitting your brain and you're like oh
she's beautiful
exactly so it's not just there no and
you could even do like dating app data
like you know behind the scenes if you
have a dating app it ranks you one to
ten yeah so like behind this behind the
scenes like you have a rating and and it
sounds good
yeah it's what are your matches look
like that's your rating what they look
like yeah yeah because that's what I bet
you did yeah so like top top five
percent or two percent of guys get get
top 10 percent of girl or something like
that or top 20 percent of girls
and so what you have to filter when you
get them all
right
go ahead what'd you say I just think
it'd be very different to What
specifically women rate themselves oh
yeah yeah I mean I mean we're told from
a young age we're special you're
princesses
I don't understand why women don't
understand I don't understand why women
don't realize that men controlled rating
the same way you guys control the rating
for us we control the rating for you and
you are always trying to pick your own
rating
oh no he smells you don't smell nice you
don't make it ratings these are all
ratings yeah we don't even give you that
much ratings man her face on all that
but she got a fat ass cool like Mana
cool we're nice with you look we're
actually quite easy the second we start
going in you don't have standards so how
can you raise it up
you just took the words out of my mouth
because the second I go into standards
you like lose your mind like who do you
think you are what do you bring to the
table I'm like yo I just wanted my milk
my breakfast made in the morning I want
you to say good morning to me and be
nice did you get breakfast though sorry
I said do you get breakfast just another
Bowl man
that's enough
when you when you go into like standards
and very firm objective kind of levels I
know it's a lot of a lot of women I know
go into this whole like post-modern like
but what is easy everyone's kind of
beautiful it's like the Lions start
getting blurred I wanna play Oh I want
to play a game
[Music]
who does anyone hear a thin skin
everyone with thick skin here okay okay
because I don't I don't want anyone to
cry
okay okay so I want everyone all right
first to start rate yourself one to ten
it looks wise yeah it looks wise just
looks
now now I want the guys to hurt the
girls
so she's she's a she's a 10 but minus 10
because she's my man's wife in it okay
okay
um spiritual lady how do you know I'm
spiritual because as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible